bernard debré donc l'invitée de début de
cette édition du 7 8 maire de saint cyr
l'école on parle plus d'urbanisme avec
vous mais des municipales politique vous
serez à nouveau candidat en mars
prochain donc c'est un nouveau mandat
vous nous l'aviez dit la dernière fois
que vous étiez venu sur ce plateau la
semaine dernière il ya une dizaine de
jours les instances de l'ump se sont
réunis vous avez eu l'investiture
officielle de l'ump il n'y aura pas
d'autres candidatures en tout cas
d'autres candidats ne se sont pas
présentés pour revendiquer l'investiture
ump nous on avait évoqué pendant un
temps là en tout cas dans les rumeurs la
possibilité du retour de philippe lavaud
l'ancien maire ump vous nous aviez dit
sur ce plateau que vous ne vouliez pas
en entendre parler sur votre liste ça
n'a pas changé ça n'a pas changé
dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes à la
proche de ces élections municipales pour
tout vous dire elle me semble encore
loin
il ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
on a fait un programme en 2007 que nous
avons présentée aux électeurs et je
voudrais réaliser mon programme vous
avez le sentiment que j'ai encore un peu
de ses programmes encore j'ai une crèche
dont la construction n'a pas encore
démarré mais qui va ouvrir la fin de
l'année dans le quartier de l'épi d'or
j'avais promis un terrain de foot
synthétique ça pose beaucoup de
problèmes mais ce matin la dernière
réunion technique a eu lieu c'est
faisable il ouvrira aussi avant la fin
de l'année donc on continue de
travailler on a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de travail encore à faire ou
seulement n'occuperait pour tout vous
dire à partir du mois de septembre mais
pour autant vous avez tous les mots
anticiper un petit peu puisque vous avez
commandé un sondage sur votre commune
exactement d'ailleurs l'opposition vous
le reprocher puisque savez ça a été
payée avec l'argent de la ville à paris
à quatorze mille euros j'ai vu qu'il
s'en servait puisque j'ai vu dans un art
et que monsieur fargniers
le site 14000 euros environ pour ce
sondage qui a été payé par la ville
pourquoi avoir demandé un tel sondage et
pourquoi l'avoir fait et payer également
par la communauté par votre ville
écoutez il ya beaucoup de villes qui
font des sondages je crois que c'est
quelque chose de très courant et c'est
insisté un peu votre popularité non non
non proclame popularité c'est dans la
rue alors à quoi a servi ce sondage à
voir quels étaient les attentes des gens
puisque les principales questions qui
étaient posées dans ce sondage s'étaient
justement qu'est ce qu'ils attendaient
et c'est assez amusante d'ailleurs que
les réponses n'étaient pas toutes en
adéquation avec un sondage national qui
avait été fait quelques semaines avant
et dans le classement des dix priorités
des gens on ne retrouvait pas la même
chose mais c'était tout à fait en relief
avec ceux qui émargent à saint cyr ou
ceux qui manquent vous avez testé des
listes si vous avez testé une possible
candidate d'union nationale une wallonne
pour voir éventuellement si ça vous
ferait perdre des points dans les
sondages sur le premier tour par exemple
je vais citer les résultats en 2008 vous
aviez obtenu 50 points 56% des aides et
voix sur ce premier tour des municipales
les socialistes 34 48 % et puis il ya eu
daniel fargniers aussi sa candidature
14,96 pour sens de lier mentionné
là vous pensez que le même rapport de
force va s'appliquer ce pauvre savez les
années passent
il ya un bilan
je crois que le les candidats ne seront
pas les mêmes à part moi me to hell mans
justement sur les candidats sur
l'opposition daniel fargniers qui venu
sur ce plateau récemment il a été
conseiller municipal d'opposition
pendant une vingtaine d'années sur saint
cyr l'école 89 89 il ne se représentera
pas aux prochaines élections il a
d'ailleurs déjà de démissionner puisque
visiblement au sein de l'opposition il
ya quelques quelques tensions sur
l'improbable de candidats -le nom
d'étienne erasmus a été mentionné ce
serait plutôt une candidature de
centre-droit vous avez une préférence
pour votre adversaire ou en tout cas
comment vous comment vous regardez ses
mouvements au sein de votre opposition
je vous parle grand chose à dire là
dessus son départ de daniel fargniers
par exemple il est parti c'est son je
pense que il avait d'excellentes raisons
il a expliqué qu'il y avait des raisons
familiales il va quitter la salle il y
en avait 12 ans travaillent ils
souhaitaient passer le relais c'est à
lui de le dire même si certains font des
supputations et sur les candidats et
génère ainsi mus par exemple lui aurait
préféré daniel farm et gaitan desjardins
vous avez une préférence sur le candidat
cette combinatoire préférence mais j'ai
l'impression que on aura le droit aux
deux ont pensé qu'il y aura plusieurs
listes donc où elle se présentait sur la
commune avec des tendances a plutôt bien
vous sauver bagdad et san siro des
points communs ce que tout le monde veut
être calife à la place du calife
fictivement saint cyr l'école est une
histoire agitée on a eu l'occasion d'en
parler on aura encore l'occasion d'en
reparler bien sûr toujours un mot
concernant la politique ça ne concerne
pas saint cyr mais david douillet il ya
eu du changement puisque la semaine
dernière et nous avait annoncé qu'il ne
se présenterait pas aux municipales ni à
rouen ni ailleurs et finalement il sera
sur la liste de karl olive voici par
ailleurs conseiller général ump david
douillet est en troisième position sur
cette liste je vais mettre toutes mes
forces dans la campagne afin de
reconquérir la ville qui a basculé à
gauche en 2008 at il déclaré au parisien
comme quoi rien n'est jamais acquis
puisque quelques jours auparavant je
vous le disais nous avait déclaré qu'il
ne serait pas candidat sur le fait de
faire basculer cette commune par exemple
celle de communes de poissy est ce qu il
yad autres communes dans le secteur qui
se regardaient actuellement qui sont
scrutés par l'ump qui pourrait basculer
à droite
voulez vous qu'il ya un enjeu un enjeu
important mais certains maires est une
dernière le dise une réserve importante
à la fois en formation en finance
du parti socialiste c'est la communauté
d'agglomération il suffit de faire
basculer une ville on sent que les on
sent que les forces de l'ump se
concentre sur cette communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce qui
concerne le département c'est un enjeu
important quelle commune
où je pense que les trois communes sont
regardés mais il y en a une qui est
peut-être un rythme éthiquement parlant
plus facile que les autres se manie le m
ou mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
regarder ni la berrière nini trappe très
bien merci bernard de berne est revenu
sur ce plateau évoquer cette question
politique municipale ceux qui veulent en
savoir un petit peu plus je vous
rappelle que à l'antenne actuellement
est diffusée sur tv fil 78 municipales
2014 troisième édition de notre rendez
vous politique que vous pouvez aussi
consulter sur notre site internet grâce
au replay merci à vous